hi i'm kirby i play deaf hello i'm
gwendolyn and i play lucifer morningstar
hi i'm mason alexander park and i play
desire hey i'm tom and i play dream hi
i'm pat knows what i play matthew the
raven hi i'm jenna coleman and i play
joanne constantly time hi i'm viviana
champagne i'm playing lucian hi my name
is
[Music]
and we are here with buzzfeed to take a
quiz to find out which character
we really are
[Music]
first which quality do you most admire
in a friend loyalty
empathy confidence dedication sense of
adventure or sense of humor
sense of humor you want someone that can
laugh when you screw up when you're like
oh my god i'm so strong they're like hey
you know what sense of humor implies
they have perspective about stuff
that's exactly where i'm gonna go too
that's the button i'm going to touch
which the sound man character would you
trust with a secret
matthew the raven able
death desire gilbert irving the gargoyle
definitely not desire no desire would
use that against you or find a way to
use it against you in the future exactly
no i think the gargoyle would be
very cute very trusting i think i'd go
with gilbert
i'm gonna say abel ah
i'm going with irving i want to keep my
cards to my chest you're just not saying
you actually have to say
oh what you have to say i'm loud
matthew the raven i think it seems like
a wild card but
i spent a lot of time with that guy he
can't even see her
he can't give him
i take those secrets anyway abel is such
a sweet guy but i feel like he would
stupidly blur
not meaning to be mean but he
even though i play matthew
i'm going to go with gilbert
pick a neil gaiman book or comic to read
good diamonds
stardust
american gods
coraline and nancy boyes
norse mythology
oh okay the nazi boys the good omens is
so great because it's like hitchhiker's
guide but for the apocalypse but
american god is great too
neil can't you write one crappy book so
we can just not have to consider that
the hell okay the nazi boys i'm gonna go
with carline i'm picking good omens
i love american gods yeah i'm getting
american guards i feel like coraline was
the thing that introduced me to neil so
i just i have to pick that yeah love
quiet i'm going to say norse mythology
because i haven't read it yet i'm also
going to say norse mythology because i
love eternal beings
fabulous casting over here pick an actor
from another netflix project to star in
a movie with
tom ellis
uh his photograph taken by getty images
kristen bell also with getty images
jean-page
ryder kerry washington and matt smith
he seems really nice
and that's the only reason why i'll go
with it reggae and why would you go with
america it just
oh okay but fun fact he's actually also
um zimbabwean oh okay so that's fine oh
i i went with matt smith we both did
simon stephen's place ah so you went
with someone you've worked with before
no no different players but
comes from
saying okay yes
i say i said what you say i've already
acted with kristen bell in a netflix
project so i'm going to have to cross it
out guys you know i have a quite an
extensive uh imdb listing so i'd say
carrie washington because i feel like
she's so
intense and so we just up your game as
an actor to have to act opposite her
uh yeah uh pick a dream you would want
to come true uh getting to travel
through time
bringing someone back from the dead
meeting the love of your life never
growing old these are all pretty good uh
becoming the smartest person in the
world
um or the ability to travel through
dreams i like that meeting the love of
your life is like a fantasy here like
pick something that could never ever
really happen being happy
[Music]
the love of your life
could be the smart thing
yeah yeah all of these have a creepy
monkey's paw quality to them where you
would pick one of these and then there's
and then there's a catch all these seem
to have a weird catch to them getting
traveled through time what if you travel
and all you do is keep messing up the
time stream every time you do something
i can do pretty much all of these things
except for the growing old parts never
growing old
i would uh travel through time that's
what i would pick i'd definitely bring
someone back from the dead i don't feel
like being the smartest person in the
world would actually be that cool i
think that'd be horrible
i think it wouldn't be very fun it could
be pure and say meeting love with your
life but i'm not i'm going to say travel
through time yeah
i'm never growing old i'm going to
travel with three dreams all right i'm
going to never grow up
and finally choose a book to tv
adaptation to binge watch
normal people watchman outlander big
little lies bridgeton game of thrones do
you know what i'm going to do what
because my boyfriend loves it and i
haven't watched all of it i want to go
with friends oh thank you
yeah i'm going to say normal people
because i go watch that again and again
and again yeah i think i might say
normal people i want to watch watchmen
again because that show was brilliant
i'll go with game of thrones
no way
what'd you get oh my god oh my god how
about i be a stream
what i know heck yeah wow i got lucifer
rose yay that's right
[Music]
[Music]
did you hear me come on you did go on my
mom
[Applause]
you fixed his phone so you didn't upset
him
thanks buzzfeed thank you thank you
make sure to watch the sandman on
netflix
[Music]
[Music]
you